space or makes make room for a second
hearing
sometime
in the next two weeks after this real
next three weeks before the event
as long as as long as we're in time but
i mean we're happy that it's a well-run
establishment and uh
you have a good event plan which is
uh very comprehensive and very health
and safety conscious
uh so
it's just it's just a matter of getting
the details sorted out with
the shuttle bus
and the local taxis to the to the
satisfaction of the environmental health
officer but i will just ask our legal
officer to give us a briefing about the
basically the legalities of it because
he's on top of it really you know i'm
not
okay james thank you thank you well
thank you chad um what effectively is
going to happen is that this matter will
be deferred to a second hearing date
now um that means the hearing is
essentially still in the committee
meeting is still still in progress
essentially so no reasons will need to
be given for that decision today and
it's up to you mr oliver to to
put forward to miss douglas uh
whatever proposals you wish
hopefully they can be
resolved by way of a matter of agreement
in which case there may not be a need
for a second hearing
in so far as your points that you made
in relation to the first day of your
event is concerned
obviously if you one of the ways you
could reach if you can't reach an
agreement about the second date with ms
duckworth one of the things you could
reach agreement about is that the second
day won't take place
so that the temporary event notice can
be modified between you just to deal
with the first date um therefore
preserving your position insofar as
that's concerned um
it would seem that if if if the
committee is they they're going to deal
with it in this way
it will save you the need to submit
another
10 application
and it will save ms duckworth the need
for generating yet more paperwork in in
putting in a notice of objection or
would only get us to the same place that
we're at at the moment
and if that is acceptable to you all
um then there's no legal um
impediment to stopping the committee
doing that and
deferring the hearing at the committee
meeting until a date to be notified
okay james thanks for that so clearly
the first date isn't an issue it's just
it's just about reaching agreement um
about the second date and i think we're
all on the same page about what we what
we need to achieve with that
so hopefully there won't be a need for a
second hearing
but we've obviously reserved
you know the the space to do it if we
actually need to so
is everybody clear about what's going to
happen so there's no decision at the
moment but we're deferring it really to
to to reach agreement between
environmental health
yeah i'm happy that i've got to go away
and just repurpose the paperwork to
satisfy all the terms if we can reach
that
we may go through if there's no way we
can reach it we'll take day two off
i'm i'm happy with that resolve i'll do
the best i can to supply nikola
hopefully within the next week because
that would make it easier for everyone
within the next week without everything
that's required
okay well thanks mr oliver that's that's
really helpful everybody okay with that
we're clear about what what's going to
happen
okay well for now i'll thank you and uh
if we don't meet again next week
i wish you all the best with the venue
with you with the
thank you